- It is stunning to me
that the majority of people
that are watching this right
now, have first world problems.
(instrumental piano music)
I see so many young people rightfully so,
and makes me admire
them, be so altruistic.
Yet they're so weak inside themselves.
They act as though they
want to help the world,
as a way to build confid-, you know,
it's a facade.
- Ego.
- It's ego.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And that's fine and it's a
lot better than other things.
So I don't judge.
It's just, I wasn't able
to give this much back
until I scratched a
couple things for myself.
- I'm stuck, I'm in rut.
- Because?
- Because I just finished
army, which is two years,
so I just came by, I really
don't know what I want to do
I don't qualify right now.
- You gotta try stuff.
The biggest reason you don't
know what you want to do
is you haven't tasted enough things
and the biggest reason you
not tasting enough things,
is you worried about finding it too fast.
It's Patience.
- Lost in life.
- It's Patience, you can't be lost in life
when you're this young,
you just have to change your mindset.
Like to me when I look around,
this many people being in their 20s,
like everybody judging
themselves way too early.
What I would do is gather as
many experiences as possible.
Almost everything is perspective.
I think, I think I'm just starting,
so imagine what I think for most of you.
- Thank you so much.
- Patience.
Patience, you know whether
it's your parents or yourself
or people, everybody is trying
to prove something so early.
Too many people view post
university as like oh shit
this is now real and I'm lost,
they don't put it in the context
of being alive for a 100 years
and realizing they are
only 20% of the way done.
Everybody's got strengths and weaknesses,
what a 60 year old has in
experience but doesn't have time.
So they trade on experience.
What youth has is time,
you can literally do four different things
over the next two years,
six months at a time
to figure out, everything
that you think you might like,
you should try to do.
But that's not what people tell you to do.
- Yeah, they tell you to get a job.
- Your not lost in life your
just early in the process.
You know what I mean?
You're lost by other peoples standards
not by your actual, if you
actually took it practically,
you haven't even started.
(instrumental piano music)